IT.
IT IS TIGHT.
MONDAY IS ALMOST OVER AND IT'S
TIME FOR OUR VERY IMPORTANT
BREAKING NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
THE PRESIDENT JUST WRAPS UP
ANOTHER HUGE RALLY.
THIS TIME IN WEST COLUMBIA,
SOUTH CAROLINA WHERE HE TOOK ON
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU REMEMBER WHAT I SAID.
WE'RE GOING TO START WINNING
AGAIN.
WE'RE WINNING.
WE'RE WINNING NOW LIKE WE
HAVEN'T WON BEFORE.
>> LIKE WE HAVE NOT WON BEFORE.
WE'RE WINNING WITH OUR MILITARY.
OUR MILITARY IS NOW BEING BUILT
UP LIKE YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE.
WE'RE WINNING WITH OUR MILITARY.
WE'RE WINNING ON TRADE.
WE'RE DEFENDING OUR BORDERS.
COUNTRY.
YOU DON'T HAVE A COUNTRY.
[CHEERS & APPLAUSE]
[CHANTING]
>> OH, IT'S HAPPENING.
IT'S HAPPENING.
IT'S NOT "BUILD THAT WALL"
BECAUSE WE'RE BUILDING IT.
>> Sean: LET'S BUILD THAT WAY.
WE'RE ALMOST 1 1/2 YEARS INTO
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
MANY ON THE LEFT, THIS IS
SERIOUS.
THEY'RE TOTALLY COMPLETELY
UTTERLY PSYCHOTIC AND UNHINGED.
REMEMBER, THIS WASN'T SUPPOSED
TO HAPPEN.
DONALD TRUMP WAS NEVER SUPPOSED
TO BE ELECTED BY YOU THE PEOPLE.
IN FACT, WHEN HE WAS INAUGURATED
IN JANUARY, MANY ON THE LEFT,
MANY DEMOCRATS, MELTED DOWN,
TRUMP AND THE WHITE HOUSE
HIMSELF?
>> YES, I'M ANGRY.
YES, I AM OUTRAGED.
YES, I HAVE THOUGHTS A LOT ABOUT
BLOWING UP THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME AN
ACTOR ASSASSINATED A PRESIDENT?
I WANT TO CLARIFY.
I'M NOT AN ACTOR.
I
HOWEVER, IT'S BEEN AWHILE.
SECOND, THIS WAS SAID ABOUT
OBAMA IN THE EARLY MONTHS OF HIM
BECOMING PRESIDENT.
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT KATHY
GRIFFIN'S BLOODY SEVERED HEAD,
EVERY OTHER DAY.
THIS IS WHY THIS IS HAPPENING.
THE LEFT, NOT ONLY -- THEY NEVER
EXPECTED DONALD TRUMP TO WIN,
HE'S A THREAT TO EVERYTHING
WRONG ABOUT THEM.
HIS SUCCESS IS THE WORST
NIGHTMARE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY NEED DONALD
TRUMP TO FAIL IF THE DEMOCRATS
EVER WANT TO REGAIN POWER.
WELL, THE POWER THEY'RE HOPING
FOR.
THEY HAVE TO PRAY FOR FAILURE.
THAT MEANS YOU FAIL.
WOMEN WILL BE FORGOTTEN.
BILL MAHR IS HOPING FOR A
RECESSION.
REALLY?
DOESN'T AFFECT HIM.
HERE WE ARE 1 1/2 YEARS INTO THE
PRESIDENCY OF DONALD TRUMP.
500 DAYS THE ECONOMY IS BOOMING.
RECORD UNEMPLOYMENT RATES IN 14
STATES.
WE HAVE MORE JOBS THAN PEOPLE ON
INEMPLOYMENT EVER RECORDED FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS, HISPANIC,
WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST GDP GROWTH
IN OVER A DECADE.
WE HAVE THE LOWEST TAX CUTS.
WE HAD A DEMOLISHING OF
BURDENSOME REGULATIONS.
SUCCESSFUL NORTH KOREA
NEGOTIATIONS.
JERUSALEM PROMISED BY MANY SO
MANY PRESIDENTS IS THE CAPITOL
OF ISRAEL AND SO MUCH MORE.
WITH EACH SUCCESS, THE DEMOCRATS
MORE REMOTE AND THEY FEEL IT.
THEY DON'T LIKE HIS SUCCESS.
THAT'S WHY IT'S GETTING LOUDER
AND MORE INSANE BY THE DAY.
THE LEFT IS NOW TARGETING THOSE
THAT WORK AND SUPPORT PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
LOOK AT THIS.
NEW JERSEY SO-CALLED SENATOR
PRESIDENT WANT-TO-BE COREY
BOOKER IS CALLING FOR AMERICANS
SHE'S BEEN CALLING FOR HIS
IMPEACHMENT.
MAXINE WATERS IS URGING
SUPPORTERS TO ACCOST TRUMP
ALLIES WHEREVER THEY GO.
THIS IS DANGEROUS.
WATCH.
>> YOU HAVE MEMBERS OF YOUR
CABINET THAT HAVE BEEN BOOED OUT
OF RESTAURANTS.
WHO ARE NOW PROTESTING, TAKING
UP AT THEIR HOUSE.
DEPARTMENT STORE, AT A GASOLINE
STATION, YOU GET OUT AND YOU
CREATE A CRY.
AND YOU TELL THEM THEY'RE NOT
WELCOME ANYMORE, ANYWHERE.
>> Sean: NATURALLY THOSE
ASSOCIATED WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
ARE NOW BEING TARGETED BY THE
VICIOUSLY ANGRY LEFT WING ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
THEY'RE DOING TO IT WOMEN AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SHE WILL JOIN NEWS A FEW
MINUTES, PAM BONDI.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THREE HUGE GUYS CAME UP AND
SO THEN A TROOPER, MY TROOPER
CAME UP.
MY GIRLFRIEND AND I GOT OUR
TICKETS.
WE'RE HEADED IN.
THEN THEY RAN IN AND CIRCLED ME
WHERE I COULD NOT GET INTO THE
THEATER.
THEY STOPPED ME.
SO HE CAME UP THEN AND STOPPED
THEM.
WE WENT INTO THE THEATER.
THOUGHT IT WAS DIFFUSED.
WE'RE UP GETTING POPCORN AT THE
CONCESSION STAND AND THEY CAME
UP AGAIN.
EVERY CURSE WORD IN THE BOOK.
THIS FAR FROM MY FACE.
ONE SPIT ON MY HEAD.
>> Sean: PICKING ON WOMEN AND
ATTORNEY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL GIVE
US MORE DETAILS ON THAT.
SHE'S THE LATEST TRUMP ALLY TO
BE TARGETED.
SARAH SANDERS WAS LITERALLY
THROWN OUT OF A WEEKEND, THIS
WEEKEND IN RESTAURANT NAMED THE
RED HEN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MANY BY NOW HEARD I WAS
THROWN OUT OF A RESTAURANT WHERE
I ATTEMPTED TO HAVE DINNER WITH
I WAS ASKED TO LEAVE BECAUSE I
WORKED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE WERE ALLOWED TO DISAGREE BUT
WE SHOULD DO SO FREELY AND
WITHOUT FEAR OF HARM, THIS GOES
ENCOURAGED TO KIDNAP MY
CHILDREN.
THIS WEEKEND A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS CALLED FOR PEOPLE TO
PUSH BACK AND MAKE CLEAR TO
THOSE SERVING THEIR COUNTRY AND
THIS ADMINISTRATION THAT THEY'RE
HEALTHY DEBATE ON IDEAS AND
POLITICAL PHILOSOPHY IS
IMPORTANT.
BUT THE CALLS FOR HARASSMENT AND
PUSH FOR ANY TRUMP SUPPORTER TO
AVOID THE PUBLIC IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> Sean: AGAIN, THREATENING
WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
WHO IS WRONG WITH YOUR PEOPLE ON
THE LEFT?
ACCORDING TO SANDERS FATHER,
MIKE HUCKABEE, THE HARASSMENT
DIDN'T END THERE.
>> ONCE SARAH AND HER FAMILY
LEFT AND OF COURSE SARAH WAS
ASKED TO PLEASE VACATE, SARAH
AND HER HUSBAND JUST WENT HOME.
THEY HAD SORT OF HAD ENOUGH.
FOR THE REST OF HER FAMILY, THEY
WENT ACROSS THE STREET TO A
DIFFERENT RESTAURANT.
THE OWNER OF THE RED HEN --
NOBODY TOLD THIS -- THEN
FOLLOWED THEM ACROSS THE STREET,
CALLED PEOPLE AND ORGANIZED A
PROTEST YELLING AND SCREAMING AT
THEM FROM OUTSIDE THE OTHER
RESTAURANT AND CREATING THIS
SCENE.
RED HEN RESTAURANT SHOULD FOCUS
ON CLEANING THE RESTAURANT
SANDERS.
I ALWAYS HAD A RULE, IF A
RESTAURANT IS DIRTY ON THE
OUTSIDE, IT'S DIRTY ON THE
INSIDE.
WHAT IS DIRTY IS THE POLITICAL
DISCRIMINATION COMING A FEW DAYS
AFTER OUR DHS SECRETARY NIELSON
OF CONTROL.
TAKE A LOOK.
DINNER HERE?
OVER 10,000 CHILDREN SEPARATED
FROM THEIR PARENTS.
RESTAURANT OF ALL PLACES.
SHAME ON YOU!
>> SHAME!
SHAME!
>> FASCIST PIG.
>> Sean: IT GETS WORSE.
ON FRIDAY MORNING, MORE
RECORDINGS OF CRYING CHILDREN.
NOBODY IS NOW SAFE FROM WHAT A
MOB MENTALITY OF THE LEFT.
NOT EVEN CHILDREN ARE SAFE AS
PRESIDENT'S 12-YEAR-OLD SON, THE
TWITTER FROM PETER FONDA.
YEAH.
HANOI JANE'S BROTHER.
SHE TWEETED, WE SHOULD RIP BARON
TRIP FROM HIS MOTHER'S ARMS, PUT
HIM IN A CAGE WITH PEDOPHILES
AND SEE IF THE MOTHER WILL STAND
UP AGAINST THE GIANT BLOB THAT
SHE'S MARRIED TO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S 4-YEAR-OLD
GRANDDAUGHTER WAS ALSO
THREATENED ON TWITTER BY A
CANADIAN WRITER.
BOTH OF THESE PEOPLE APOLOGIZED
FOR THESE HORRIFIC THREATS.
WHERE ARE THE ARRESTS?
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO THREATEN
THE FIRST FAMILY.
WHAT ABOUT MADONNA?
THINKING ABOUT BLOWING UP THE
LEFT?
I THOUGHT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HAD A MONOPOLY ON PEACE AND
LOVE?
APPARENTLY NOT.
CHECK THIS OUT.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT, NEWS
BUSTERS, YOUR ESTABLISHMENT
CORRUPT DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA IN
AMERICA TOTALLY IGNORED THE
STORY ABOUT TRUMP'S 4-YEAR-OLD
GRANDDAUGHTER.
WHILE THE LEFT'S ANTI-TRUMP RAGE
IS SPINNING OUT OF CONTROL, SOME
IN THE MEDIA, AS SICK AS THEY
ARE, ARE ACTUALLY ADDING FUEL TO
THE FIRE.
THEY CAN'T CONTROL THEMSELVES.
THEY HAVE ALL LOST IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PROBLEM THAT SARAH
SANDERS HAD OVER THE WEEKEND,
WHICH IS A ABSOLUTELY LEGITIMATE
PROBLEM, BUT WHO CARES?
SHOULD SOMEONE WHO LIES
SHOULD THEY FACE ANY KIND OF
>> IS IT 0 OKAY THEY CAN'T GO TO
RESTAURANTS AND GET HECKLED?
>> IT'S SPEAKING TRUTH TO POWER.
>> YOU MAKE CHOICES IN LIFE.
YOU MAKE CHOICES IN LIFE.
DECEITFUL ADMINISTRATION.
>> LET'S TAKE A STEP BACK AND
REMEMBER ALL OF THIS HATRED
COMING FROM THE LEFT.
IT WAS INITIALLY SPURRED OVER
REPORTS THAT CHILDREN WERE BEING
FORCIBLY SEPARATED FROM THEIR
PARENTS AFTER ATTEMPTING TO
CROSS THE U.S. MEXICO BORDER
ILLEGALLY.
IT WAS DONALD TRUMP LAST WEEK,
HALTING ANY SEPARATION OF
FAMILIES UNTIL CONGRESS CAN DO
THEIR JOB AND CHANGE THE LAW AS
THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE A LONG
TIME AGO.
THAT DIDN'T STOP MANY CRAZIES ON
THE LEFT FROM DEMONIZING DONALD
TRUMP.
MANY CHEERED, FOR EXAMPLE.
THIS "TIME" MAGAZINE COVER.
YOU SEE THAT?
THERE'S A BIG BAD HORRIBLE
PRESIDENT AND A LITTLE GIRL WHO
IS CRYING, BECAUSE THE LITTLE
GIRL, ACCORDING TO "TIME"
MAGAZINE HAD BEEN SEPARATED FROM
HER MOTHER AND FATHER.
WELL, THE ONLY PROBLEM IS, THE
GIRL WAS NEVER SEPARATED FROM
THE MAGAZINE COVER, LIKE SO MUCH
IN THE NEWS TODAY IS A LIE.
TIME BELIEVE IT OR NOT IS
STANDING BY THEIR COVER FOR SALE
NOW AT A BOOK STORE NEAR YOU.
THE MEDIA WONDERS WHY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CALL THEM FAKE
NEWS.
ARE NOT FAIR OR BALANCED
EXTENSION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND THAT'S PLANE AND
SIMPLE.
THE AGENDA FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, BY THE WAY, IF THEY GET
ELECTED IS SIMPLE.
IT'S NOT A SHOCK HERE.
DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER THE
DEMOCRATS RUNNING FROM
CALIFORNIA, WEST VIRGINIA,
THEY'RE ALL WORKING TOWARDS THE
SAME THING.
WHAT DO THEY DO?
WE'RE GOING TO IMPEACH TRUMP
TRUE BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO TELL
YOU.
MAXINE, STOP SAYING IT.
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT, DON'T SAY
IT.
THEY WANT TO KEEP OBAMACARE AND
OPEN BORDERS.
YEAH, THEY WANT THEIR CRUMBS
THEY WANT THE CRUMBS BACK SO
THEY CAN SPEND YOUR MONEY.
NOW, THAT'S WHY WHAT WE'RE NOW
HEADING INTO.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
COVERAGE ON THIS.
THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
MID-TERM ELECTION IN MODERN
HISTORY.
LIKE EVERY TWO TO FOUR YEARS,
THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE NOW IN THE
CRAZY SEASON AND IN THE CRAZY
SEASON, THEY USE SAME PLAYBOOK
AND THAT IS A CAMPAIGN OF
IDENTITY POLITICS TO CONVINCE
YOU REPUBLICANS ARE EVIL.
THEY CLAIM REPUBLICANS ARE
RACEST AND SEXIST AND MASSAGE
AND REPUBLICANS WANT DIRTY AIR
AND WATER AND KILL YOUR
WANT TO THROW HER OVER THE
CLIFF.
THE DEMONSTRATE THIS FACT,
TONIGHT IS A BE HANNITY HISTORY
TO DIVIDE THIS COUNTRY SO THAT
THEY CAN CONVINCE YOU
REPUBLICANS ARE ALL EVIL JUST TO
WIN VOTES.
THEY'LL SAY AND DO ANYTHING FOR
POWER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MANY REPUBLICANS TALK IN
CODED RACIAL LANGUAGE ABOUT
LOSERS.
THEY DEMONIZE PRESIDENT OBAMA
AND ENCOURAGE THE PARANOID
FRINGE.
>> IF YOU ACCEPT THE SUPPORT OF
PLANNED SYMPATHIZERS BEFORE YOU
ARE PRESIDENT, YOU WILL ACCEPT
THEIR SUPPORT AFTER YOU'RE
PRESIDENT.
UNCHAINED WALL STREET.
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT YA'LL BACK
IN CHAINS.
>> IT'S WRONG WHAT THE LEADER OF
AN ACCURATE CENSUS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO COUNT EVERYONE
THAT THEY DON'T THINK THEY CAN
COUNT ON.
DUMP THE BASKETBALL OR SINK A
IF YOU MERELY HAVE THE POTENTIAL
TO BE A LEADER IN YOUR COMMUNITY
AND BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER.
DON'T TELL ME WE'VE GOT A COLOR
BLIND SOCIETY.
>> MY FATHER WAS KILLED IN
TEXAS.
HE WAS BLACK.
SO WHEN GOVERNOR GEORGE W. BUSH
REFUSED TO SUPPORT HAD A CRIMES
LEGISLATION, IT WAS LIKE MY
FATHER WAS KILLED ALL OVER
AGAIN.
>> WHEN YOU DON'T VOTE, YOU LET
ANOTHER CHURCH EXPLODE.
♪♪
>> THAT'S PAUL RYAN THROWING
GRAND ANY OVER THE CLIFF.
FLASH FORWARD.
WE CLEARLY HAVE A NEW LEVEL OF
NASTINESS COMING FROM THE LEFT.
LOOKING INSANE, WHICH IS ALL
LIBERALS TODAY.
LOOK AT ACTOR TOM ARNOLD.
TRYING TO SAY ANYTHING NEGATIVE.
HE'S HAVING A HARD TIME WITH
WORDS.
ANSWERING SIMPLE QUESTIONS.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY TAPES OF THE
PRESIDENT THAT THE PUBLIC IS NOT
ALREADY AWARE OF?
>> YES.
>> YOU CAN'T TELL ME YOU SAY THE
CONTENT OF THE TAPES BECAUSE YOU
WANT PEOPLE TO WATCH YOUR SHOW.
>> I DO.
>> WE'RE HAVING FUN WITH THESE
TRUMP TAPES.
>> DID MICHAEL COHEN TELL YOU --
JUST YES OR NO -- THAT HE'S
COOPERATING WITH THE
AUTHORITIES?
QUESTION?
>> NO.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO ANSWER
QUESTION?
>> RIGHT.
>> OKAY.
>> BECAUSE --
>> WILL YOU LET US KNOW WHAT YOU
LEARN OVER THE WEEKEND SINCE
YOU'RE SPENDING THE WEEKEND WITH
MICHAEL COHEN?
>> NO.
>> Sean: BEST 30 SECONDS CNN
EVER HAD.
THEY SAID NOTHING IN TRYING
TRUMP TO A LITANY OF
CONSPIRACIES THAT HE HAS NOTHING
TO DO WHICH IS EVEN HARDER.
FINALLY, ON THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL," THEY'RE CASTING DOUBT
ON MUELLER'S ONGOING WITCH HUNT
CLAIMING "IT'S A TAINTED AND
POLITICAL BIAS.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE I.G.'S RECORD
IS OPENING EYES TO WHAT WE'VE
BEEN SHOWING YOU NEARLY A YEAR."
NOW NINE REPUBLICAN LAWMAKER
ARES ASKING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVIDE THE NAMES
OF EVERY PERSON, PAST AND
PRESENT THAT WORKED FOR
MUELLER'S PROBE.
THIS COMES AS ROD ROSENSTEIN,
THE FIB DIRECTOR WRAY, ARE
SETTING UP THIS THURSDAY BEFORE
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IN
WHAT WILL BE AN EXPLOSIVE AND
REVEALING HEARING.
THIS WEDNESDAY DISGRACED FBI
AGENT PETER STRZOK WILL TESTIFY
ON CAP TOP HILL BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS.
OPEN THE DOORS.
SHOW SOME SUNLIGHT.
FINALLY, WE HAVE A BOMB SHELL
NEW REPORT FROM THE HILL
DETAILING HOW THE FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR COMEY, PERSONALLY
KILLED A DEAL BETWEEN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND WIKILEAKS JULIAN
ASSANGE.
PROOF REGARDING THE SOURCE OF
WHEN I INTERVIEWED HIM IN
JANUARY OF LAST YEAR.
>> DID RUSSIA GIVE YOU THIS
INFORMATION OR ANYBODY
ASSOCIATED WITH RUSSIA?
>> OUR SOURCE IS NOT A STATE
PARTY.
SO THE ANSWER FOR OUR
INTERACTIONS IS NO.
>> Sean: YOU DID NOT GET THIS
INFORMATION ABOUT THE DNC, JOHN
1000% YOU DIDN'T GET IT FROM
RUSSIA OR ANYBODY ASSOCIATED
WITH RUSSIA?
>> WE CAN SAY -- WE HAVE SAID
REPEATEDLY OVER THE LAST TWO
NOT STATE PARTIES.
>> Sean: WE COULD HAVE GOTTEN
THE TRUTH FROM JULIAN ASSANGE?
WHAT DID COMEY HIDE?
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T
YET KNOW ABOUT?
AFTER ALL, WE'VE BEEN THROUGH,
MAKE THE DEAL.
WAS IT RUSSIA?
PROVE IT.
GET IT FROM ASSANGE.
LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THE